es ist krieg das ist jetzt sechs monate
her dass wir hier im studio saßen und
das erstmal begreifen mussten was wir da
gerade sehen die bilder die uns hier am
frühen morgen erreicht haben aus der
ukraine damals von unseren reportern die
hauptstadt kiew erschüttert von
explosionen und dann wenig später ist es
eben hell geworden in der ukraine und
die menschen die sind auch dann noch in
ihren bunkern geblieben denn über ihn
rasend plötzlich russische jets ja es
ist jetzt krieg jetzt ist das keine
warnung mehr keine drohung mehr das ist
realität
haben das damals nach diesem
kriegsbeginn am 24 februar so versucht
in worte und in bilder zu fassen putins
blut damals und die ersten bilder die
ersten fotos aus diesen ersten kriegs
stunden von beginn an dort gewesen im
krieg ist unser bild reporter paul
ronzheimer schon guten morgen paul
mitten nach kiew in die hauptstadt die
seit genau sechs monaten jetzt kriegs
hauptstadt ist und du hast bilder in
deinem kopf die nicht mehr aus dem kopf
gehen wir wollen einige dieser bilder
zeigen paul unter anderem das foto einer
frau aus der u-bahn warum dieses foto
warum geht ihr dieses foto vor allen
dingen nicht mehr aus dem kopf
es war damals das erste opfer des
krieges kann man sagen denn wir haben
sie unten in diesen u bahn schächten
interviewt wir haben mit ihr über die
situation gesprochen und nur einen tag
später wurde sie getroffen das gesicht
versetzt sie wurde dann aus der ukraine
rausgebracht also sie ist dann schnell
weg hier aus kiel aber es hat uns ganz
persönlich sozusagen gezeigt wie schnell
es für jeden gehen kann der in diesen
stunden damals in diesen tagen durch
schief gelaufen ist sie war unterwegs
auf der seitenstraße dann getroffen eine
dreifache mutter ich kenne ihren ehemann
auch gut und sie wird immer noch
behandelt heute in deutschland die
bilder die dir in diesen sechs monaten
so intensiv im kopf geblieben sind ein
anderes bild zeigt eine schwangere die
aus dem krankenhaus raus gebracht wird
ganz eilig blutüberströmt warum ist das
eines dieser bilder paul
es zeigt die absolute brutalität mit der
die russische armee vorgegangen ist
zeigt dass überhaupt kein unterschied
gemacht wurde anders als wladimir putin
behauptet hat der zu beginn des krieges
immer gesagt hat nein nein wir greifen
in anführungszeichen nur militärische
ziele an dort kann man sehen es geht um
frauen um kinder ja sogar um schwangere
und dieser krieg hat vor niemandem halt
gemacht und dann gibt's die bilder aus
butscher natürlich die um die welt
gingen du hast es selbst sehen was dort
in butter für kriegsverbrechen begangen
worden sind von putins armee natürlich
lassen einen diese bilder nicht mehr los
du bist auch anders aus butter wieder
rausgekommen als du ein gefahren bist
wir sind dort an einem morgen nachdem
klar war dass es diese kriegsverbrechen
gegeben haben soll reingefahren den
stunden in den ersten stunden zusammen
mit vitali und wladimir klitschko und
als wir dort ankamen
eine straße wie hier und diese straße
übersät mit leichen übersät mit
zivilisten die mit den händen nach
hinten gebunden teilweise die augen zu
gebundenen man hat sehen können wie sie
erschossen wurden wie sie hingerichtet
wurden von den russischen truppen
unzählige dutzende auf dieser straße
teilweise ein mann der noch einen
kartoffelsack bei sich trug der offenbar
gerade versucht hatte irgendwie ein
bisschen nahrung zu finden während des
krieges und natürlich hat butscher fast
alles verändert muss man sagen denn kurz
vorher gab es ja den versuch auch immer
noch in der türkei zu verhandeln aber
nach butter war vielen menschen hier in
der ukraine auch mir klar dass diese
russische armee zumindest in teilen so
verbrecherisch mit so einer brutalität
vorgeht das ist ganz ganz schwer es hier
die beiden an einen tisch zu bekommen
und butscher hat insofern alles
verändert als es die ganze brutalität
dieses krieges auf den auf einer straße
gezeigt hat das sind die bilder die wir
so besonders im kopf geblieben sind paul
deine ganz persönliche kriegs bilanz
nach sechs monaten krieg jetzt ja auch
für dich dort in dem land jetzt stehst
du vor panzern dort mitten in kiew und
das ist eine ganz besondere geschichte
denn am morgen des 24
februar begann ja die erste rakete die
ersten bomben welle auf kiew und da
wollten auch langsam die panzer richtung
hauptstadt richtung kiew zu und die
russische armee hatte sich das so
vorgestellt doch kiew sehr schnell
einnehmen zu können diese panzer sollten
hier eigentlich mittlerweile durch die
straßen fahren der russischen armee
gehören die diese straßen dominiert ist
es anders gekommen
russland wollte eine siegesparaden genau
hier keinem ich stehe hier auf der
straße zum mai dann also die straße die
insofern berühmt geworden ist dass damit
alles begonnen hat 2013 die proteste
hunderttausende hier die für freiheit
gegen korruption auf die straße gegangen
sind danach begann der krieg im osten
bereits und hier wollte wladimir putin
wo ich stehe mit russischen panzern und
russischen soldaten zeigen das ist
unsere stadt er hat er immer gesagt die
ukraine existiert auf seiner sichtlich
das sei alles russland und wir sehen
hinter mir jetzt die kaputten panzer die
panzer die die ukrainische armee erobert
hat und man muss sagen dass sie knapp
halten konnten das sechs monate nach
beginn dieses krieges kiew so aussieht
wie er aussieht und das jetzt hier eine
vermeintliche sieges parade umgedreht
wurde eben mit kaputten russischen
panzern und die ukraine zeigen können
schaut her die hauptstadt gehört uns
noch immer dass es etwas womit am anfang
des krieges kai die wenigsten gerechnet
hätten danke bild reporter paul
ronzheimer die wichtigste frage in
diesen tagen ist natürlich wie lange
noch wie lange dauert das alles noch was
antwortest du auf diese frage die wir
natürlich alle in wahrheit gar nicht
beantworten können paul
ich kann sie auch nicht beantworten ich
glaube es wird noch lange dauern ich
glaube es kommt darauf an ob der westen
bereit ist die ukraine entschiedener zu
unterstützen denn unter den bedingungen
die putin formuliert die russland
formuliert unter den bedingungen wie man
will dass die ukraine kapituliert so
werden die menschen hier nicht
kapitulieren sie werden ihr land nicht
einfach hergeben
egal wie viele opfer das kostet das ist
so wahnsinnig dramatisch auch kiew zu
sehen teilweise die invaliden die
zurückkommen aus dem krieg gestern
nicolai getroffen der nur noch ein bein
hat und der trotzdem gesagt hat ich
hatte glück der rest meiner brigade
viele viele sind tot und ich hatte glück
und das ist etwas was mir von gestern im
kopf geblieben ist glück im august im
august 2022 in kiew bedeutet nicht tot
zu sein auch wenn man nur noch in bayern
hat sagte unser bild reporter paul
ronzheimer am morgen der jetzt ja vor
sechs monaten uns erinnern lässt an die
ersten krieg ziehen aus der ukraine als
wir hier waren im studio und mit unseren
reporter noch mit paul damals gesprochen
haben und erst mal begreifen mussten was
dort gerade in diesem land passiert
danke
[Musik]